[موسيقى]
تعمق القيمة في هذا الشارع أسفل
هذا الطريق ، وكوخ الصفيح بدون نوافذ هذا
هو مطعم تديره امرأة
أطباقه جيدة جدًا ، وعليك الانتظار لمدة
عام لتجربتها التي تحتاجها mlz وكنت أطهو
طعام Cajun من أجل  ما لا يقل
عن 60 عامًا
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بك في مطعم الزينة
الذي لا يوجد فيه طاقم عمل ولا قائمة طعام ، ما عليك سوى الطاهي
ألينا في مطبخها في منزله في
أحد أكثر الأماكن تواضعًا ، وهو
متجر لحام سابق كان
يمتلكه ابنها في السابق.  هذا إلى المطبخ لأنني
أحب الطهي وليس لديك أن
ابني كان بصدد نقله إلى
مكان أكبر ، فبدلاً من إغلاقه
سألني إذا كنت أرغب في
تحويل هذا إلى مطبخ أريده
أن يكون مفتوحًا حيث طباخنا وأين
يأكلون لأنهم لا يستطيعون رؤية ما
تفعله معظم الأشخاص الذين يأتون
يريدون المشاركة في ما تفعله
[موسيقى]
طعام كاجون أعتقد أنه أفضل طعام
في العالم.  أثيرت عليه
طبخًا بسيطًا تبدأ به ب  قم
بتتبيل البصل
والثوم بكمية كبيرة من الكرفس والثوم ثم تقلى ذلك
بكمية قليلة من الزيت ثم تبدأ في
إضافة المكونات الأخرى الخاصة بك مهما كان
ما تطبخه إذا كان جمبو جامبو أو
جمبري مقلي ،
فما هو أفضل من ذلك
[موسيقى
] جيدة  نظرًا لأن هذا يبدو أن Eden و Lina's
يمكن أن يكونا خادعين ، فلا توجد طرق سير
ويمكن إجراء الحجوزات فقط من خلال الاتصال
بها على هاتفها الأرضي ، شكرًا لك على
الاتصال ، لم أكن أرغب في المشي لأنني
أعتقد أنني كنت سأكون
حزينًا جدًا لأنني أعيش بسيطًا  الحياة وهذه
هي الطريقة التي أحب حياتي بها ، لا يوجد
جهاز كمبيوتر ، فقط هاتف بسيط
أحجزه حتى العام المقبل
، دائمًا ما أحجزه قبل عام واحد
، ونعم ، يعجبني أنه من الأفضل أن أحصل على أكثر
من 40 عامًا كما فعلت لينا
نجحنا كثيرًا في جذب انتباه
المجلات السياسيين
والطهاة المشاهير ، وقد توافد الناس من جميع أنحاء العالم
على مطبخ L Tina لتناول
طعامها الآسيوي الأصيل ، ولكن بالنسبة إلى Xena ،
فإن التجربة تدور حول جعل
الناس يشعرون  في
المنزل كعائلة عندما يأتي الناس ، فهو عبارة عن
مبنى من 10 ، لذا يقولون أين نحن
ولا تدرك أن هذا موجود ولكن
عندما يخطوون إلى المطبخ ، يكون هذا
عالمًا مختلفًا ، أعتقد حقًا أنهم
سعداء بالشعور  السلام في المطبخ
ثم عائلة المانجو
التي لم تلتق ببعضها البعض
ربما من عام إلى ثلاث سنوات وتجلب
السعادة لهم وتجلب
السعادة لي ولدت لأخدم حتى لا أخدم
[موسيقى]